what's up Star Talk fans you know a lot
of you have reached out to me and asked
what am I doing a comedy special well
guess what it's happening that's right
this fall I'm taping my first science
comedy special here in Manhattan so if
you're going to be in the area I want
you to be there because I need the most
science literate audience that I can
have and that means you so go to Chuck
Nice comic.com and use code Star Talk
for your exclusive chance to make a
pre-sale purchase for the tickets it's a
very limited supply of tickets so you
want to do it as early as possible and
that means now Chuck nicecomic.com use
code StarTalk and we'll see you this
fall with the rest of the Star Talk gang
thank you
[Music]
this is Star Talk Neil deGrasse Tyson
here you're a personal astrophysicist
got with me Chuck Knight Chuck how you
doing man oh great man how's it going
all right you're my my co-host
extraordinaire
I don't tell you that as often as I want
to I'll take it anytime
we've got a special guest today a long
time friend and colleague Madame Saturn
yes does she have a name beyond that I
don't know and I don't think so but
until we verify let's call her Carol and
Porco Carolyn welcome back to start talk
thank you and it's great to be here and
hello to both of you you both look great
it's good to see you excellent excellent
we got you on because we're going to
talk about
world-changing civilization moving space
images yes and you've been a part of
this this parade of cosmic perspectives
that have come to us from Photography in
space
and I'm delighted to sort of get your
take on this and what roles you played
in the past present and maybe even the
future so Carolyn I've got a three-line
bio for you this is I think cap
encapsulates why we've got you on the
show today you remember you're a member
of the Voyager Imaging team forager was
launched back in 1977 so you've been at
this for a while you're also a leader
and and how did the Imaging team of
Cassini that was a NASA's mission to
Saturn and uh currently you're visiting
scholar at UC Berkeley and my favorite
planet after Earth is Saturn and so
every day I was looking at my inbox to
see if a new beautiful image was coming
from your Saturn portfolio so uh Carolyn
welcome back to StarTalk thank you
thanks for having me and let me add to
that three-line resume Carolyn that on
July 19th
2013.
uh you oversaw the an image taken by the
Cassini spacecraft while it orbited
Saturn called The Day the Earth smiled
yes and many have called that the
greatest selfie ever taken so Calvin as
I've come to understand the early
planetary probes as conceived by NASA
did not contain cameras they contain all
manner of sophisticated scientific
equipment to measure like magnetic
fields and and and and plasma densities
and all this but not photos and so what
do you know about the history of this
this resistance yeah it has a very
interesting history and not surprising
Carl Sagan is involved in this because
he was one of one of the original uh
planetary planetary scientists in fact
the Voyager Imaging team leader Brad
Smith referred to Carl as the first
planetary scientist but anyway
uh it was the first mariner mission to
Venus uh this was going to be the first
mission to a planet because we didn't
begin with you know Ranger survey or so
on to the Moon
uh it was the first mission to Venus and
the Venus is of course the closest
planet to Earth so why wouldn't it be
Venus you go to the closest place yeah
good idea so anyway
the scientists the scientists involved
in that mission did not want to carry a
camera and they said if this was told to
me by Carl they said that they thought
essentially that cameras were for kids
you know there was no really uh you know
important signs that could be done with
a camera and it was called a call tried
to convince them that I wouldn't be a
you know a sensible thing to leave off
the camera uh and they didn't believe
him and he lost the battle but he won
the war because uh while future missions
thankfully carried cameras and it's just
that it just shows you how silly people
can be because what is an Imaging device
especially a space Imaging device that
takes uh you know the summer scene and
turns it into an array of numbers which
get relayed back to Mother Earth
what is that except a bunch of detectors
in fact in the case of Cassini a million
a thousand on the side uh a million
individual detectors arrayed in two
Dimensions they're they're okay these
scientists were okay with carrying one
detector that could just look in one
spot take whatever information it needed
for some reason they did not like the
idea of a two-dimensional array of a
million of these things uh but anyway
that's it's true it was there was really
strong pushback against Karen mccamba
and we know isn't it it's not well it's
not because they were just ignorant it's
that if you're going to carry a camera
that means you can't carry something
else right every ounce matters on these
space missions okay but what they
couldn't see was the utility in imaging
data that's really what it came down to
but you know with cameras I don't they
didn't do this on the early missions but
with cameras of course you can take
movies you could see phenomena as
they're developing and you could put
filters in front of cameras and you can
uh you know put uh you make spectral
measurements and so on but but anyway I
just as an interesting footnote to the
history of Planetary Exploration that it
was actually pushed back it gives
cameras when cameras I mean just look at
that handles of of uh you know the the
discoveries that have been made in the
planetary program and how much of it is
on is there because of Imaging devices
so you're saying these original
planetary scientists were boneheaded
that's what you're saying no and you
said it you said okay
I'll tell you
on scientists so I'm just not going to
mention any names
so tell me about the pale blue dot and
Voyager okay so I love talking because
we're speaking you lived you lived it so
this is oral history as well as
scientific history yes I'm going to tell
it I'm going to tell it to you from my
point of view I was made an Imaging team
member officially after I graduated
uh Caltech in May and then I finally
moved to Arizona to be a postdoc under
Brad Smith the Voyager Imaging team
leader uh and that's when I was became
an official member of the Voyager
Imaging team and soon after that I began
hulking around this idea to take a
picture of the Earth from the outer
solar system and I had in mind you know
the perspective that it would give us of
our place I also had in mind that it
would show what
aliens coming to the Earth would see you
know they'd it was to take a picture
over here than all the other planets and
so right aliens coming to the solar
system would then see Earth in the
distance yes yes that's right so I just
thought this would be a cool thing to do
and I began Hawking it around I spoke to
Brad Smith about this I even ended up
speaking to Ed Stone about this and I
was told basically by it was Ed Stone
the head of the jet propulsion Labs back
then sorry I should be careful about
this uh I spoke to Ed Stone about this
who was the project scientist Voyager
gotcha and he would later become would
he later become head of the jet
propulsion yes he did for a time he was
the head of yeah after Voyager but but
anyway so um I I was told by Ed Stone
you know no we're not going to take an
image like this unless you can find some
science to it Ed was a professor at
Caltech and one of the just the a gem of
a guy and he was trying to encourage me
he said go find some signs you can do
with this and maybe we'll do it and I
couldn't think of any and I ended up
going off and doing something else but
meanwhile
a few years go by and it's a 1988 and I
find out that Carl Sagan
had proposed the same thing uh he had
done it a a year or two before I did but
he was also having trouble getting
anyone to you know want to get
interested in this certainly um not the
project leadership not at Stone but the
other the the managers at JPL because
they would have been a dangerous thing
to do in those days take a picture like
that because the High Gain antenna on
Voyager was always 100 of the time
pointed towards the Earth and they
feared if you had to take the High Gain
antenna off the Earth
well in order to move the camera into
place to take a picture
we might lose the spacecraft so it
turned out
not until
1989 was it clear that we were going to
be able to do this oh and I should say
that I told Carl left or I found out
that he was trying to do it I met him at
a DPS meeting division of planetary
Sciences meeting and said you know I was
trying to do this too and I didn't get
anywhere he said why don't you join me
and help us so I was tasked with
Computing the exposure times for uh for
the pictures we were going to take we
ended up taking six six of the eight
planets and
and and the picture finally was what
happened and it really happened that's
why Carl really gets the credit here
he had to go to NASA headquarters speak
to NASA headquarters people to get
permission and get the funding to take
this picture and I think the funding
amounted to uh in present-day dollars
would have adapted to something like
asking for four million dollars uh you
know it was uh it was asking a lot I
guess to do this so anyway it finally
got done and lots of people poo pooed
this idea and people thought you only
it's only going to be less than a pixel
how could this possibly be an
interesting
an interesting picture but as we all
know it's what Carl had to say about it
and the way he romanced and he turned it
into an allegory in the human condition
that has turned it the picture and the
phrase pale blue dot
into a meme if you will you know it
really and and they um well like I said
it's an allegory of of where we stand so
that that established
but I
almost a protocol in Planetary
Exploration because it seems like every
Mission since then has taken a picture
of the Earth so there's pictures of the
law of the earth taken from the surface
of Mars pictures of the Earth from the
Galileo spacecraft on its way to Jupiter
and so on and of course so Carolyn I'm
stuck on something
why would pointing a camera cost four
million dollars
what was the film made of like gold I
mean what like what
is is it the procedures it was
just the effort the overhead it was
keeping the the marching Army that at
JPL
that managed and ran the you know the
whole project and and this took care of
the spacecraft keeping them all on board
for some extra time that was basically
part of it or most of it okay so it's
the
it's during the time you are taking that
picture they're not doing anything else
that they should have been doing and so
then you can cost that up and you get to
four million dollars that's what you're
saying there no we didn't do that
picture until the mission the Voyager
planetary portion of the mission was
over
so no no
you have to keep the marching Army
marching that's what it is okay yes yes
that makes sense yes I I it was
basically overtime
it's like we can't do this we have to
pay overtime
everybody gets time and a half
you're laughing buddy Martin it really
was sort of like that I have to
interlude after quick interlude
um I have an excerpt here
from Carl Sagan's pale blue dot the book
okay which is probably among the most
quoted sentences of the entire book if
you allow me
okay okay thank you by the way you're
supposed to be listening to this while
you're looking okay
our posturings our imagined
self-importance the delusion that we
have some privileged position in the
universe are challenged by this point of
pale light
our planet is a lonely Speck in the
great enveloping Cosmic dark
in our obscurity in all this vastness
there is no hint that help will come
from elsewhere to save us from ourselves
and it goes on and on and on but that
and that's just representatively
beautiful
of a very long passage and it's a take
on that pale blue dot
so Carolyn you wanted to reprise this so
what happened there
well
um I was chosen to be the Imaging team
leader on Cassini actually just months
later
uh well actually let me let me let me
prep you here just briefly
um not many people know who who have
seen these beautiful passages from Carl
about the pale blue dot that a big part
of this recitation is Carl explaining
what a pixel is this was early before
that became common knowledge right what
a pixel how to think about it how much
resolution is there so he goes through a
whole disclaimer
uh or a primer on how to look at a
digital image and what a pixel isn't
that Earth barely fills a pixel and but
one thing that he did not make clear is
that Earth barely fills a pixel because
of the resolution of the camera a higher
resolution camera would have had many
more pixels to represent Earth but he
never really went there and you're left
thinking oh my gosh from space Earth is
only one pixel so we now fast forward
how many years we go to the Carolyn is
ready to just knock knock one out of the
park so count pick us up at Saturn now
we're up at now we're up to two pixels
well okay but let me let me just say let
me just say I have to be I'm going to
nerd out on you is that okay
I'm just gonna say that it's not only
the size of the pixel it is the
diffraction limit of the camera that
counts too so there are you know you
could have you can have a CCD with a
billion pixels on his side in you know
at the focal plane of your telescope but
if your telescope has a certain
diffraction limit you can't see anything
better than that so so it's a little bit
more tricky but anyway fast forward
where where uh I I get to be the
damaging team leader on Cassini less
than a year
from the time the Voyager pill blue dot
was taken and I had at the top of my
bucket list certain items that I wanted
to do one was I was going to make sure
that we did what the Voyager people
really never got a good chance to do and
that was
as much as we could put out true color
images because I wanted people to see
what the solar system with Saturn and
everything in it really looked like and
then another was
um where we could have uh take use the
cameras as movie cameras and just take
repeated imagery so that we could see
phenomena as they were happening and we
did that in Spades and then finally it
was to redo the pale blue dot and it
didn't happen
it didn't really happen I didn't have
the time we didn't have the the uh
things just weren't you know all set up
the way they should just again to put
this in time context the Voyager was
launched 1977. it was passing Neptune in
1980 so it's done with the planets no
1980 no no no no no no no no
89. okay no but the pebble black was
1990 correct Valentine's Day 1990.
gotcha so it took 13 years to get far
enough out beyond the orbit of Neptune
for everyone to say we're done with the
voyager's scientific Mission now let's
do this frivolous stuff like take a
picture of Earth and so with the four
million dollars the the craft stays
online takes the picture so now it's
1990. yes pale blue dot happen
Valentine's Day 1990 November 13th 1990
I got a phone call from NASA
headquarters telling me out of the
Imaging team leader I'm sure those
people who didn't want to pay overtime
were like damn
well anyway so uh and my first team
meeting my first team meeting was I
think early December of 1990 and that's
what I told my you know I didn't tell
them we wanted we're going to do the
pale blue dot but that's where I set my
goals for the team but anyway so
fast forward a number of years again to
20 uh I don't know what it was 2010 11
and I'm starting to think where can I
find the time or in the in the uh the
plans for all the imagery we were going
to do uh where can I slot in another
pale blue dot and in doing that
trying to think of where we were going
to put it it occurred to me how great it
would be if we just do the pale blue dot
with a Twist and that twist was going to
be that I thought we'll invite people
the world over
to participate in this we'll tell them
ahead of time not after the image is
taken like everybody else had done up
until that point we'll tell them ahead
of time at this certain time
and date we're going to take a picture
of you here on the earth that the window
the picture ticking window lasts 15
minutes we want you all to go out you
know straighten up comb your hair go out
you know and look up
you know at the sky even if you're on
the other side of the earth I saw Chuck
in that photo he had like
he had spinach in his teeth and clearly
I was not wearing pants
okay
all right
anyway like that wasn't so clear Chuck
don't worry about it
okay so I remember I remember Carolyn
because there were news articles about
this to get everybody to participate so
do you know at the end of the day how
many people looked up and smiled I I
don't really know I think we estimated
tens of thousands and I really to be
honest with you I had plans to make it a
big event
um I even had applied to the Ted people
you know the Ted conference right they
give out a million dollar prize for a
big project and I thought this is just
going to be up there Ally and I applied
to them and they didn't uh they didn't
choose it but the idea was to just you
know make it a big event a teaching
moment all around the globe
um and that never happened but anyway
people did participate and we said you
know just go out
look up at the sky think of all of us
here on this planet all in Earth's
creatures on one planet think of our
isolation and the Blackness of space and
think of how precious life is and our
own lives are on this planet and just
smile at being alive on a pale blue dot
and that was kind of the directive and
we set up a website people wrote in and
it was really moving for a lot of people
so I was very in the picture of course
turned out like just it's a killer
picture stunning with in the shadow of
Saturn it's one of one of the more
brilliant photos I think ever taken in
space I know of anything and it was the
first time we ever had seen the Earth
and Saturn and the whole thing together
just like that so uh and I've been told
Neil literally people I know who are in
your audiences this has been happening
for years they write me an email they
say do you know Neil deGrasse Tyson is
showing your image right now and he's
saying great things about you
so anyway thank you for that thank you
yeah yeah I I call you out every time I
say Carolyn borko uh and I also let
people know that you're active on social
media so they can find you okay good
yeah thank you so Carolyn when I look at
these Cassini images I'm I'm often
struck by the colors and so what makes
the different colors
um the different colors basically come
down
to
two two different phenomena one is just
basically different materials different
compositions okay different in the
atmosphere of Saturn different compounds
organic materials or of one kind or
another
uh they have different colors
right so that's that's what you're
seeing in the atmosphere of Saturn the
same thing in the Rings uh there are
impurities in the Rings and they give
the Rings even though they're mostly
water largely water they're impurities
and they can from afar they can up
look like color to the your eye
okay of course it's frozen water just to
be clear yeah it's right yes it's not a
bathtub right right a lot of bathtub
but there are times when you are seeing
a phenomenon known as refraction uh or
diffraction to different phenomena that
actually they work uh if you're looking
at different angles the object at
different angles you'll see different
colors so it's it's just light
electromagnetic radiation interacting
with atoms of different types different
types of atoms that can produce
different colors okay and as far as true
color goes
um it was it's a very hard thing to do
to get true color what you would see
first of all if you were hanging out
floating above Saturn first you have to
appreciate what you would see would be a
hundred times fainter than what you
would see here because Saturn is 10
times farther away from the Sun uh-huh
so automatically when we take the
picture and we expose the picture with
we leave the shutter open for longer the
long exposure for longer than your eyes
residence time on your retina we're
already cheating right so it's always
going to look somewhat different than it
would uh would to you if you were there
but we it wouldn't be cheating chuck if
you had huge eyeballs I was going to say
if I if if that's CCD chips
if you had elsa-sized eyeballs
why don't we do that topic another time
another time yeah okay of course cool
yeah all right so so Carolyn uh so when
I look at the think of the inventory uh
profound photos of course earthrise from
Apollo 8 comes to mind could you can you
reflect on that
well that was
um that was the first time
the globe of people first saw the Earth
from afar and I mean there had been
pictures like it taken but it wasn't to
become as popular as the apolloi moon uh
earthrise and it had to you know it in
some sense it can be
um you can attribute that you can
attribute the the
environmental movement to that picture
because it was the first time we see
ourselves as a globe it's an uncorrupted
unpoliticized view of our planet and you
know we know of course that we all live
on it and it's good it just people have
such a powerful as you must know when
you show that picture the day there it
smiled and I've been going around doing
the same thing showing him people have a
very
a very strong response to to recognizing
where and what we are yeah why it just
just knowing what the Earth would look
like in the skies of another world it's
it's it's the you are here
exactly and it's not only you are here
but you are here on this just insanely
small and fragile looking thing with
nothing around it I mean just com just
complete Blackness all around bear asked
in the universe that's that's a title of
a book
it's not your next book no no I don't
know
so Carolyn can you foresee a photo yet
to be taken that might have be as
impactful as those that have come before
um it sounds like a no
I have to think I'd have to think about
it okay while you're thinking let's go
to questions Chuck you've got some
questions from our patreon members yes
we do all right line them up what do you
have let's start off with uh Casey here
and uh actually uh and each of these
members have been told that we would be
speaking to you today Carolyn so these
are tuned these are bespoke for your
presence on this program okay okay
absolutely as Casey says Dr Tyson Lord
nice Dr Porco uh Casey here from Florida
with a question for Carolyn what was the
most interesting thing you learned from
the Cassini Mission and what upcoming
Mission has you most excited I like that
all right oh gee I mean what we learned
so many things so many pick your
favorite child then because
okay I'm gonna give two can I give two
all right two one it's one everybody
expects me to say because really is the
thing that has grabbed me ever since we
found it and that was learning what what
exists uh on Enceladus it's the ocean
that has got just in a complex organic
compounds on it has hints of
hydrothermal activity that presumably is
taking place on the sea floor of
Enceladus as an ocean underneath it
that's what I'm trying to say and and
it's expressing itself into space of the
form of geysers and a plume that we can
fly through Cassini flew through it to
sample it and we know a lot about it now
and um and it's just it really is
despite what anybody else tells you it
is the low-hanging fruit in our solar
system to go search for life and to be
to be at the Forefront of that I mean we
took the pictures we were the ones who
found the hundred geysers you know
lofting into space uh and there's um
there's good reason to believe that a
very good reason to believe that that
ocean uh with it that's the geysers are
coming out of four fractions of the
South polar terrain and there's good
reason to believe that the liquid water
from which those gauzers are created
comes all the way up to the surface
literally like it could be like Old
Faithful except not with an intermittent
kind of character but water that comes
all the way up to the surface and I mean
it just doesn't get any more exciting
than that the way if they're fish down
there then some of the fish might have
come up in the geyser you could have
freeze-dried fish on the surface of
Enceladus no because
bad
bad it's better because it's bad because
there's very it's not likely this
complex life down there you need more
energy that is a than is available there
but microbes hey microbes are cool don't
disrespect microbes okay so microbes
float up in there on the surface well I
said I've always said it could be
snowing microbes in those geysers okay I
like my fish all right I'll give you the
microbes okay give me a give me a
microbe I'll take a microbe I still like
fish but all right go on that's all
right and what upcoming space mission
planetary mission do you most look
forward to uh well okay so I'm I'm I
won't be around for it but when we go
back to Enceladus land on the surface
and we can do the whole the whole kitten
caboodle we can measure the geophysical
activity underneath the surface
seismically we can uh we can stand there
and just have the stuff fall on us we
could collect to our hearts content and
we could really do a bang-up job well
search searching for life in debt and
sell it Association and apparently you
expect to be dead you expect to be dead
by this well it's going to take so long
before that
happened okay how
how bad that when we land we don't
contaminate if there are microbes there
the good question good question good
question and this brings up boy this
brings another topic I don't know if we
want to do it this time or not another
time uh you know NASA treats this as for
all the criticisms people have about
NASA they treat planetary protection
very seriously so we would have to go
back with an absolutely like
pristine clean spacecraft contaminated
with no microbes from Earth or else you
know we could be measuring our own our
own uh you know viruses yeah so we don't
want to do that so but but it just puts
it's puts before us the Specter of
having the people from the commercial
space side of things now just crazily
flying into space with what will be
hundreds of thousands of satellites have
lowered dormant they're talking about
missions to go to Enceladus they want to
they I've heard plans done to go land on
Enceladus or flight through its plume uh
I doubt any commercial Enterprise will
ever be able would want to spend the
money you know it's actually Fork over
the Bucks to ensure the cleanliness of a
spacecraft
hmm yeah so so it's got to be NASA to
lead this otherwise we worry about
forward contamination right what it is
we're trying to observe that's what I
was trying to say now yeah yeah okay all
right no yeah that makes sense NASA
cares and you know everybody else just
wants the money
you're absolutely right
yeah Carolyn is one of the plumes from
Enceladus make one of the Rings of
Saturn isn't there some ring made by a
plume it's not just well all the there's
geysers there's hundred there's a
hundred that we counted my research
group actually this is my own research
we counted about a hundred individual
geysers but if you had higher resolution
there's probably more all those geysers
make a plume so don't get confused
there's hundreds of guys they all make a
plume we showed that those geysers the
the biggest among them the the most you
know pronounced uh actually
most of that stuff falls down the solid
stuff falls down on the ground back on
Enceladus but some four percent of the
material ends up going into the e-ring
it forms the e-ring
yeah so okay that's very cool yes it was
very cool and we showed that we did
modeling simulations of these um
tendrils that you see coming off
Enceladus uh the law of distances tens
of thousands of kilometers away and we
could show that they were created by the
geyser so it was a it was like a slam
dunk it was really cool by the way the
Pentagon has an e-ring just thought I'd
tell you oh all right I'll keep that in
mind so what did I hear recently Carolyn
about uh tasking the James Webb Space
Telescope to look at this very phenomena
yes the James Webb Space Telescope which
by the way I'm sure it's blown your mind
it's blown my mind it's blown
everybody's Minds it's just fantastic
the way that whole thing has been
working perfectly and it also took a
look at Enceladus okay we've never seen
the PLO from you know anywhere other
than Saturn actually Voyager also saw
the plume but saintly uh and here we
have James Webb now has the ability to
look uh at this plume and monitor it and
and there's a collection of scientists
they were the the team that did this uh
and they're you know they're gonna keep
looking at it I guess what I'm saying it
means that we can continue to monitor it
before the mission goes back long after
from Deb that's what I mean okay there
you go unless you live forever which
might still happen all right so Chuck
time for a couple more questions what do
you have okay here we go this is Samuel
tomka and Samuel says hello Dr Porco uh
greetings from Slovakia my name is
Samuel and I was wondering will the day
come when we can
live stream video as our probes
allow us to watch in real time
flybys of celestial bodies why don't we
already have such a system in place yeah
so videos
um well okay so what are we the question
is you know you're not going to have
somebody out there taking a video of a
spacecraft one player flat it so he
doesn't mean those kind of videos uh and
we actually have sort of done things
like that but I mean to you know
remember video
is lots and lots of data volume and you
have to get that stuff down to the
ground and and we have lots of
instruments that want to take data and
get their data down to the ground so you
we can't an indefinite amount of data
volume
even though it would be cool to do so
videos take a lot of space a lot of
downlink we call it so but we have we
did take imagery uh we did this you
could look at the sunclubs.org website
and we have a little
page called theater well and video clips
or whatever where we made video clips
for example when we flew by iapidus and
we put together some imagery it's you
know it's kind of clunky but we were
able to show what it looked like as we
went by so Cyclops uh is the name of
what then it stands for a Cassini
Imaging Central laboratory for
operations so it's
c-i-c-l-o-p-s and it was the center it
was the center where we we the Imaging
team actually my staff members and I uh
set up the Uplink and downlink
operations for the Imaging team nice
okay and now since that's disbanded and
there's no more of that
cyclops.org is the website that's my
website where all the uh the Saturn
imagery is and lots of other stuff we
can find it there excellent excellent
yes all right Chuck give me more
okay this is Captain James Riley and he
says hello Dr Porco I've heard that the
Hubble Deep Field image was used uh was
a use of director's time aimed at an
empty point in space since that worked
out so well are we doing more at aiming
at empty spots or are there telescopes
scheduled to pretty much lock up on
things that we just want to better look
at like nothing
I think I think there are there are
telescopes on the ground and Neil
probably knows this better than I do
telescopes uh that are on spacecraft or
plan to be on spacecraft that will do
surveys of the entire sky so they're not
just looking at one tiny little bit
they're doing entire surveys well just
to be clear it's not a survey of known
objects it's just a survey of areas of
the sky no matter what's there that
doesn't matter it's a survey of the sky
the entire sky okay so that's better
than just you know looking at one little
spot and this brings up something I
would love to talk about if we can and
that is that there are plans for
enormous telescopes ground-based
telescopes the giant Magellan telescope
or the extra large telescope I these are
just enormous telescopes to be built on
the ground to be able to look at the
heavens from the surface of the Earth
and um I am deeply concerned about all
the the traffic that will be in lower
thorbent well that is going to all these
satellites these internet constellations
that are going to impair ground-based
observations not only in the visible
because they'll be streaking across
fields of you uh and there's going to be
many many more of them in the future but
also in the radio region of the spectrum
it's going to harm radio observations
even search for extraterrestrial
intelligence and you know what else
it'll do it creates signatures of moving
objects in the sky when you might be
trying to find an asteroid that has our
name on it headed for towards us and if
the noise level of imagery goes up you
could possibly lose one of these killer
asteroids there's there's lots of bad
things that could happen and right now
the whole thing is just it's poorly if
at all regulated so it's there's
insufficient monitoring tracking they're
all in protocols for what happens in the
event of it actually Crouch well it
really I think I'll say it again NASA
cares everybody else just wants the
money well NASA NASA is supporting this
I was very very disturbed to find out
that they're you know they want to
encourage this and I think it's a bad
thing as of about nine months ago and it
could very well have changed
there were
proposed and approved satellites a
totaling totaling 430
000. and there's now and there's now no
actually as of about six months ago
there was six thousand up there and in
order to appreciate what this means
before mid-2019 which was the first
launch of the starlink space Starling
satellite
before that
six and a half Decades of exploration by
nation states
had left an accumulation of 3 700
satellites in orbit around the Earth
about half of them were alive about half
of them were dead
and as of about
what did I say six months ago I think it
was maybe nine months ago there were six
thousand and there are proposed and
maybe already approved and proposed 430
000 that's 70 times what's up there now
so it's the end of the night sky the end
of the night oh but that's another thing
I want to say is the ninth delay
the night sky belongs to all of us it's
the only thing you can lay your eyes on
that's 13.8 billion years old I go to
the night sky to check in on the meaning
of my life I'd mean that where where
else can you find that kind of
perspective
you know and and it will be ruined it
will be ruined not only for professional
astronomers it will be ruined for people
who just love to look up and remember
where they really are
yeah you know our my uh ending comment
on every show is keep looking up and now
it's like keep looking up and look at
all the satellites that's all it is
that's all you're gonna see it's a truck
we might have time for one more question
to flip in there yeah uh wow that was
that was disturbing what we just yeah it
doesn't fit in with your humor thing so
I don't know if you'll use it but well
no believe it or not we've had uh more
Baja who is a uh uh he what he what's
his
specializing in cleaning up the space
junk yeah so he's in the department of
aerospace engineering at University of
Texas at Austin absolutely more about a
job more of a job yeah to check out his
work uh okay here we go this is Muhammad
Saif and he says hello Dr Tyson hello Dr
Porco and hopefully Chuck well thank you
Muhammad
he says my name is Saif from the land
down under my question for Carolyn is as
a part of your association with Cassini
Voyager and New Horizon
what is the least known but most
fascinating thing you have seen or
noticed
oh my goodness
um yeah what's the thing we would never
see or know that you know she can't talk
about that
but okay the second most fascinating
well okay so here's something that um I
I think is fascinating and most people
don't know about it um
we sound again this is my research group
we found in the rings of Saturn a type
of
um wave
in near the outer edge of the B ring
which I have done my thesis on many many
years ago so I was anxious to look more
closely at this and we found evidence of
these free uh normal modes of the Rings
where these waves are sloshing back and
forth uh
from the place where they get
self-excited these are not waves that
are cited by an orbiting satellite
they're self-excited they slosh up again
they they travel up against the b-ring
the outer edge of the B ring which is
held by a resonance with memes it's held
sharp they reflect off the outer edge of
the b-ring they travel inwards they
reflect off their inner uh origin point
they go back and forth and back and
forth and they can be Amplified and
there's spiral waves they can be
Amplified and you can see them actually
in the motion of the outer edge of the
b-ring and the reason why this is so
exciting is because these kind of waves
are predicted to exist
in protoplanetary discs around a
protostello discs around stars and even
in spiral galaxies in fact they can be
responsible for the spiral arms and
galaxies and you can't measure their
Motion in a galaxy because the orbital
the periods of rotation periods in a
galaxy are like 200 million years yeah
but we found the smaller version of them
the Saturn Rim equivalent in Saturn's
rings so it really was so thrilling to
find something that really exists on a
galactic scale and we found evidence of
it in Saturn's rings wow I love it in
fact that's a that's a scientist's great
dream to to discover something in their
own field that affects other fields as
well yeah in this case it's all
astrophysics but it's not often that the
planetary folks talk to the galactic
folks
we made it we put it out there so it's
there congratulations on that very good
one last thing I want to ask I got this
I'm going to end with this question
what's up with that hexagon on Saturn's
South Pole
sit gone everybody loves a hexagon
winner I don't hexagons don't belong in
a gas okay okay let's make thank you
Chuck that's how I felt uh
it's it's like a perfect hexagon yeah
made out of gas that's uh if I made out
of gas I ain't giving you a hexagon yeah
it's got to tell you I am made out of
gas and I'm letting you know right now
no hexagons here
so take us out with what the hell that
was okay so I just want to say though
whenever we posted anything about the
hexagon on our website the hits went
through the roof yeah because people
couldn't get their their head around
this and people really there were people
who genuinely thought it was crystal
energy there must be something inside
Saturn creating this it is a jet stream
just like the polo jet stream we have
here on the earth it is a just a river
of of gas that if you took it and
stretched it out so it's circling the
Pole right we'll just take it stretch it
out it would be a six
six ways six conjoined waves crests and
trollops just like that but when you
take it and you wrap it around a globe
it gives the impression that it has
signs but that's just because you're
stretching out the uh what are you
stretching are you stretching out the
crisps the crest suddenly becomes
stretched out and so that's what it is
and it's um and the reason the reason
why we found it on Voyager it's still
screaming around at something like 220
miles an hour going around Saturn you
know
30 40 years whatever it is since Voyager
uh when saw that Saturn it's because any
atmospheric systems on Saturn or any of
the giant planets that get started up
they don't run down because you don't
have a solid surface underneath the
atmosphere of any of the giant planets
so there's no friction to run them down
once they get started they continue it's
the same thing with the Great Red Spot
Jupiter right the Great Red Spot has
been doing that for hundreds of years
right at least on it at least hundreds
of years I'm gonna I'm just gonna say
that's uh that's awfully convenient
there Carolyn that's all I can say
well that's convenient what's convenient
oh you just have a perfect little
explanation for straight lines and in
nature okay
here's how to say that Chuck Chuck
that's how to say that say Carolyn if
it's so obvious why wasn't it predicted
to be there before anyone found it
there are a lot of things that are
obvious in hindsight that no one took
the time to predict so okay that's the
answer so hi Carolyn thank you for being
on Star talk once again you're
in fact you even hosted Star Talk
All-Stars back when that was a run right
part of our portfolio so I want to thank
you for your service
thank you for having me I love being
here
I need affirmations okay if we call you
madam Saturn that's okay continue
calling me Madam Saturn you know like
like you Saturn is probably my favorite
planet after the Earth yes okay
Neptune is a close third no not for me
plus second I'm sorry Neptune would be a
closer
this has been star [__] and I'm near the
grass Tyson bidding you to keep looking
up
foreign
[Music]